I'm Marty Chelsea I'm a university
professor in the Department of
Biological Sciences at Columbia
University I'm mainly interested in
nerve cells how they developed how they
function particularly the function of
nerve cells that sense touch when I was
a kid I liked science I liked math there
was a whole series of books when I was
growing up called the all about books in
there there was one about the Stars
there was one about dinosaurs there are
all sorts of wonderful books and I used
to devour these and liked them very much
I also remember when I was growing up
there were a couple of movies on TV TV
shows about science
one was called hemo the Magnificent was
all about blood and I was fascinated by
that the show was just amazing that's
something I had never really thought
about before blood and what it meant and
what it did within the body and I think
that was probably when I started being
interested in science when I was in
college I had a lot of hopes of being a
scientist and I realized that if I
wanted to be a scientist I should
probably try to work over the summer in
a lab to get some experience I did this
but unfortunately every time I did the
experiment it failed and so at the end
of the summer I convinced myself I
should never be a scientist and so I
finished up my college education did a
whole bunch of short-term jobs and one
year I found myself actually teaching
high school where I made a very
important discovery and that is that
while high school students get to have
the summer off high school teachers need
to find a job and fortunately a friend
of mine suggested that I work at a lab
from some of someone that she knew
and I went to that lab and I started
doing some experiments actually not the
experiments I was told to do I actually
started doing experiments I had thought
of boss was away I decided it would be
interesting to see these experiments
done and so I did the experiments but
only after asking for a lot of help
which is something I had never asked
before I got that help I was able to do
the experiments and to my complete
amazement the experiments worked and
having an experiment work is really
exciting and it sort of convinced me
that maybe I had misjudged the whole
idea about being a scientist and I got
excited again about that decided it was
time to go to graduate school